how to cook the perfect rice basmati
rice the king of all rice is light
fluffy delicious and i'm going to show
you how to cook it perfectly
now
start off with
400 grams of rice
rice in
spot on
so what i'm going to do now is just
rinse off the dust and the starch
cold water always
and just rinse
the rice
that stops the rice from becoming clumpy
in the pan and allows it to become
really nice light and fluffy once it's
cooked rice
into the pan now to make a plain fluffy
rice exciting we're going to infuse it
three cardamom pods
and just get the pods and just pierce
them so it allows all that flavor to
come out
cardamom pods
and then
star anise now these are beautiful whole
star anise
it makes it really nice and fragrant
salt and pepper a lot easier to season
the rice now
than it is once it's cooked you start to
break it up when you season once it's
cooked now it's basically
one part rice to one and a half part
water
600 mils always start off in cold water
cold water in
onto the gas
lid on
bring it up to the ball as quick as
possible and turn it down and let it
simmer for 8 to 10 minutes and that's
the secret behind cooking great rice
allow it to steam as it's cooking
do not lift that lid up
lid off
[Music]
it smells aromatic basically all the
water's absorbed the rice has doubled in
size and is nice and light and fluffy
take the staranise out
the cardamom pods they all should have
risen to the top
pods out
take your fork
fluff it through
basically just sort of starts to open
everything back up
once you've forked it through it becomes
really nice and light and fluffy
and there
that is perfectly cooked rice
always make the most of your leftovers
use last night's rice in stir fries
scrambled up with eggs or it's simple to
make a delicious fresh salad remember a
good cook waste nothing spicy sausage
rice
whatever you're cooking the secret to
making great food is to ensure you're
locking every last ounce of flavour in
that pan and this spicy sausage rice
does exactly that
[Music]
take these spicy sausages and pierce
that skin because i want all that
delicious spicy sausage meat out of this
casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas
bread onion less acidic than a big white
spanish onion and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because i want all that fat coming
out the sausages to sort of really help
flavor the onions onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never rush cooking an onion it's
really important to sort of give them
five to six minutes in the pan so you
can really start to caramelize them
my mouth and my pepper
slice around
wasting nothing
i want to see that sort of
little core those pips in the center no
fine diced pepper the rice is going to
be cooking for 20 minutes so i want the
veg to sort of have texture after it's
cooked peppers in
a bit of garlic two nice cloves
just slap down
off with the shell
garlic in
now i want to turn up the gas get the
pan nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in everything cools down
and you'll end up boiling the peppers
and the onions and the garlic so heat up
to maximum and then just make a well
in the center
in
now
start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the skins off and the real flavor of
that
spicy italian sausage is going to come
through
what's great about this recipe is that
you can use any type of sausage to get
the flavor and the heat you want i've
gone for the spicy italian but it's just
as good with murgues or
chorizo a teaspoon
paprika in give it that really nice
smoky flavor
rice in
and we're going to sort of basically
sear the rice we call it in the kitchen
blasting the rice where we sort of
sorted the rice for 30 seconds and it
takes on all that flavor
next white wine
so the wine sort of deglazes the pan and
washes all that flavor from the bottom
of the pan into the rice
stock in bring it up to the boil turn it
down and let it simmer
[Music]
double stop to rice
turn that gas down
and let it simmer so 12 to 15 minutes
and just give it the occasional stir
keep an eye on it now get ready to
finish it
slice spring onions diced sweet juicy
tomatoes and roughly chop earthy flat
leaf parsley
spring is in tomatoes in
off with the gas really important
otherwise everything becomes overcooked
flat leaf parsley in
but look
at the volume in that pan now that
is an amazing way to take spicy italian
sausages
to a completely different level
beautiful
[Music]
starting with my easy fragrant fried
rice
first get prepped
chopped garlic
ginger and chili
keeping the seeds for extra kick
slice spring onions
chopped spring greens
and trim ahead of broccoli
then whisk two eggs
prep done stir fry on
add a good lug of oil to a hot pan
garlic
ginger chili
next the spring greens and broccoli
add water to steam
[Music]
then cook rice this dish is perfect for
using leftover rice
make a well
add the eggs
spring onions
and a dash of fish sauce
scramble then mix
season
[Applause]
top with lime and spring onions
fragrant spiced rice pudding
i love cooking with spices but you don't
have to just cook savory dishes using
aromatics and spices across desserts
takes your puddings to a completely
different level
[Music]
first off our spices this is a fresh
vanilla pod fragrant
and packed full of flavor use the back
of the knife and flatten it that removes
all those little seeds
off the skin of the vanilla pod take
your knife
slice down the middle
and then when you open that up the smell
is incredible
take the tip of the knife and you scrape
inside and look
all those seeds
dying to come out that is incredible
there are thousands of seeds still
ingrained to the pod so put them
in
to the casserole cardamom
powerful
spicy take two little pods
place your knife on top
and lightly crack them cracking the
cardamom pods helps release all the
amazing flavour cloves
gives it that kind of
aniseed
flavor with a lot of depth
one
two three
cinnamon stick
snap and in
[Music]
just smelling that level of fragrance
you can imagine what the rice pudding's
gonna taste of turn on the heat lightly
toast those spices just a couple of
seconds and what's going to happen is
just going to sort of enhance those
spices in a way that it just draws out
an even more powerful fragrance coconut
milk in
sugar two tablespoons
milk
and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream
bring it slowly to the boil to allow the
flavours to infuse and this rice pudding
reminds me of my time in india where i
got really into that chai tea fragrance
because it was just so delicious
and so comforting
take a lime
in the lime just cuts through the
richness of the coconut gives it that
nice little bit of acidity goes
fantastically well with the cinnamon and
that fresh vanilla
nice have a taste
now let's come up to the boil give it a
nice little clean around the outside
and in with the rice
use 200 grams of pudding rice don't wash
it beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven
and just turn that down to a light
simmer and the pudding rice starts to
open up and it absorbs all that coconut
vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out three to
five minutes
boiling it rapidly the rice opens up and
it goes into mush we want to keep that
nice texture that sort of fragrant rice
pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury
i want to show you how
i take this simple delicious aromatic
rice pudding to a completely different
level here's what i do
take
two egg yolks separate them
now give that a really nice
whisk
two nice tablespoons of mascarpone
cheese
whisk that into the egg yolks
just so it's nice and smooth
it's almost like finishing the rice
pudding in a delicious custard turn off
the gas add that
into the rice pudding what happens it
starts to enrich and really thicken this
rice pudding and takes it to a
completely different level
the rice is still not cooked it's
starting to go nice and soft you can
just see how it's opening up
but looks like rich aromatic lava
bubbling away
finally great more citrus zest the lime
on top
roasted
caramelized lime zest on top of a rice
pudding
is phenomenal
then put it in the oven for 15 minutes
at 200 degrees to finish cooking the
rice and develop the intensely aromatic
flavors
look at that
an incredibly fragrant
rice pudding how beautiful is that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
i'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
[Music]
you